I truly believe I can elevate the art of
a selfie I desperately want Taye Diggs
to follow me I didn't want to do the ice
bucket challenge but I kind of wanted
someone to ask me
bless me Father for I have sinned
these are my confessions I won't be an
article unless it's a list I take at
least ten selfies for every one that I
post i unfollow and re follow people on
twitter until they follow me back
sometimes but I want to masturbate I
start on Facebook I retake BuzzFeed
quizzes till I get the results that I
want I look at my boyfriend's
ex-girlfriends Pinterest and judge her
pins if a girl posts a photo of a group
of her friends on Instagram I always
rank them I haven't finished a book in
seven years but I've read every yelp
review of my local PF Changs
sometimes I'll click like on a facebook
status just so I can click unlike I
always know when someone doesn't wish me
a happy birthday on Facebook I use
Instagram filters on dick pics I think
that Jennifer Lawrence nude photo
leagues is a disgusting symptom of the
objectification of women I totally
looked at them she looks amazing
I lost my virginity to someone I met on
hot-or-not calm he was hot I thought oh
shot my face on celebrity bodies